- You're a bit of a pioneer
in the sense of, like,
being on "Idol,"
especially, and being gay.
That was kind of a big thing,
like, being on the show
and having middle America
jump on board and vote, you know,
and I know that had to have been hard.
I have friends in the same position.
So, how do you think things have changed
for gay artists since 2009?
- Man, it's a big change.
I mean, I remember coming
off of "Idol," and, you know,
going into the mainstream
music industry label system
and them just, even if they
were excited themselves,
there was a lot of, like, question marks.
There was a lot of fear,
like, is this going to sell?
Is this going to work?
And as you know, like,
that's the name of the game for
the commercial music business.
It's a business.
- Yeah.
- So I, you know, I, it
was a bit of a struggle
to kind of hold my ground
and keep focused on my part of the deal,
which is being the artist,
being the musician,
being the guy that
wears those weird shoes.
- Yeah.
- But I, you know, it was
a lot of ups and downs,
but I'm really thankful for my experience.
And I think that the world has changed.
I think we're in a place now
within the music industry,
within the entertainment industry,
and in the world where,
yes, there's still,
you know, discrimination.
There's still problems.
There's still work to be done,
but there has been so much progress made.